gibbs is one of the most fleshed out and
deeply realized characters in the NCIS
world but when you're talking about
police procedurals a deep backstory is
rarely a good thing
Gibbs life has been a blend of
professional success and extreme
personal tragedy we're here to break it
all down Gibbs was born and raised in
the small town of Stillwater
Pennsylvania his father owned the local
general store and was a pillar of the
community
but Gibbs rebelled against the
upstanding nature of his family though
he would go on to be in the military
police young Gibbs was known around his
hometown as a juvenile delinquent he
would frequently get into fights and
other scrapes around town resenting his
father for regularly coming to the
rescue the animosity between the pair
led to a 30-year split one that only
healed when Gibbs was forced to return
to Stillwater on a case Gibbs
ultimately found a way out of his small
town his father's business partner and
best friend
LJ convinced him to join the Marines
Hipps mother took her own life via an
intentional drug overdose when he was 14
years old though his mother made the
choice with her family in mind she took
her own life so they wouldn't have to
watch her die from terminal cancer Gibbs
and his father were already on less than
ideal terms eventually they realized
that LJ had known of Gibbs mother's plan
to kill herself the grieving men pushed
him out and he fled town and disappeared
the decision to join the Marines stuck
however and Gibbs enlisted shortly after
graduating high school he lost his first
close friend in the service less than a
year after enlisting in a helicopter
crash near an American base in Okinawa
things weren't all bad though Gibbs rose
through the ranks as a military police
officer and started a relationship with
a woman back home named Shannon he met
her while waiting for the train out of
town and their relationship grew during
his early years in the Marines they were
married after his sixth year in the
service and had a child two years later
during his time in the Marines Gibbs
became an expert marksman this came into
play when he was deployed to Panama in
the late 80s in the Persian Gulf during
Operation Desert Storm
Gibbs is a man of few words so his past
comes out in dribbles in flashbacks long
time washers can piece together his
service record he was wounded during his
tour during an engagement with Iraqi
forces
semper five after awakening from a
nineteen day long coma and returning
home he was awarded the Purple Heart
though Gibbs has proven to be a talented
soldier and leader that rebellious kid
was still inside he declined to appear
for any of his medal ceremonies while
Gibbs was deployed in the Persian Gulf
his wife and eight-year-old daughter
were killed making matters worse
Gibbs wife was killed for doing what can
only be seen as the right thing
Shannon witnessed the death of one of
Gibbs fellow Marines a killing carried
out in person by cartel leader Pedro
Hernandez though it carried some extreme
dangers for her she hadn't agreed to
testify she was put into protective
custody during the trial but it proved
to be too little Shannon and her
daughter were being transported to a
safe house by an NCIS agent named Kurt
Mitchell when their car was attacked
Mitchell was shot through the head and
killed the out-of-control car crashed
killing Gibbs wife and daughter while
Gibbs first wife passed on a part of her
lived on in a core piece of gifts
personality the NCIS leader has an
incredibly long list of unbreakable
rules that he dispenses to his
subordinates at appropriate times there
are said to be 69 of them they include a
bunch of tips for good investigative
police work rules for life and tricks
that his degenerate younger self would
appreciate like quote always be specific
when you lie the idea for these
unshakable laws came from his late wife
she mentioned the fact that she was
putting together a list of rules to live
by when they first met he took this idea
and ran with it
thus memorizing his own code of conduct
carrying on her list of rules to live by
isn't the only way Gibbs has honored the
memory of his late wife he's shown
throughout the series to be a man of
action and that goes double when the
pieces involved in a plot are his
friends and family Gibbs was able to
track down cartel leader Pedro Hernandez
after he returned to the United States
and shot Hernandez in the head the
incident was investigated by NCIS agent
Lara Macy who was able to put together
that Gibbs was the man who pulled the
trigger
however she opted not to pass on this
information once she realized his
motivations for the killing Macy was
later killed over her connection to this
incident when she was stabbed to death
by a disgraced Army Ranger working for
the cartel her death was left as a
message for Gibbs it's far from the only
time that Gibbs dark past would pop up
in unfortunate ways
it's retired from the Marines in 1992
with the rank of gunnery sergeant and
began looking for something to do with
the rest of his life because of his
fondness for the NCIS officer who
investigated the deaths of his wife and
daughter he began training to become a
member of the military investigative
unit Gibbs was a probationary agent also
referred to as a Probie under the very
man who inspired his career choice agent
Michael Franks personally oversaw his
training and knew that Gibbs killed
Hernandez having stood aside to allow it
to happen
Frank's retired after a 1996 bombing in
Saudi Arabia believing that terrorist
leader Osama bin Laden was behind it the
real-life attack was ultimately pinned
on Hezbollah al Hodges though
bin Laden's involvement remained a point
of contention still he saw the denial of
his tips as playing politics and retired
in exhaustion franks handed his badge to
gibbs on the way out the door as he was
his successor as commander of the unit
this is where we find Gibbs at the start
of NCIS I didn't quit I retired
Gibbs run of bad luck is evident outside
of his career his lifelong closeness to
tragedy extends to his love life with
Gibbs frequently picking partners who
are less than faithful his first wife
died in a tragic way but he wasn't the
type to swear off marriage forever Gibbs
has been married four times in his life
with each one ending in sad situations
his second wife divorced him drained his
bank account on the way out the door and
eventually remarried to one of Gibbs
close associates she was later killed by
an extremist
Gibbs third marriage ended in a more
ordinary way he caught her in the midst
of an affair so she left him for the
other man he lost his fourth wife to his
job as Gibbs had become obsessed with
bringing a serial killer to justice the
fact that Gibbs killed a man in cold
blood before joining NCIS hangs over him
throughout his career audience has
learned about the slaying all the way
back in the third season and the
situation occasionally brought it out of
him when he was around people he truly
trusted but his team had no idea that
the man they were following was a killer
until a vigilante Network targeted Gibbs
for death after being confronted by a
judge Gibbs revealed that he killed
Hernandez while the team is quick to
move on from it indicating that his
secret is safe with them it's clear that
Gibbs is uncomfortable with so many
people knowing what he's done it flies
in the face of his fourth rule for life
best way to keep a secret keep
to yourself second best tell one other
person if you must
there is no third best check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you